meine frage an euch wäre ganz einfach
wer von euch ist der kreative kopf wenn
es um songtexte geht und noch ein
kompliment an eure arbeit erst hat
einfach die westen also bis dann yahoo
dankeschön für die frage
die sache war den songtexten das glaube
ich die es kommt darauf an wer die idee
hatte werde als dazu mehr dazu weil es
dazu zwei mal dazu
wenn jemand wenn er zum beispiel ich
sagt wir machen den song mit dem titel
dann fällt mir natürlich mehr vielleicht
ein oder anderen beim team über philipp
und je nach stimmt lockern doch stimmt
und je nachdem wer zeit hat wenn allein
unterwegs ist macht man dazu aber
normalerweise jetzt alle hin scheinen
dann zusammen daran weil so kann der
sagen ich mag es nicht was du da sagst
den text will ich nicht und so kommt
sein zustand also ich kann mich nicht
entsinnen dass es einen gibt der sagt
dass es so fertig und ihr dürft nicht
widersprechen oder siehst du das alles
jetzt sagte ich wäre derjenige der immer
unfertig und jedoch nicht widerspricht
nee quatsch gerade bei comedy
ganz wichtig und auch einen tipp an alle
die comedy machen wollen es ist immer
sehr wichtig andere meinungen einzuholen
und man sollte riskieren bei den witzen
als man sollte wirklich
alles aufschreiben und dann einfach in
der gruppe besprechen und dann ist das
auch bei uns einfach so dass wir uns
offen sagen
guter versuch alles war halt einfach
nicht lustig und
so kannst du dann aussortieren was
wirklich ein guter gag ist und deswegen
schreiben wir direkt dann schon in
zusammenarbeit